normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
good news on the horizon my friends when
you see a headline like this black lives
matter leader endorses Trump for 2024
election says the Democratic party is a
racist party that strikes at the heart
of the black family and the nuclear
family so this is a guy who helped found
a Road Island the Rhode Island BLM
chapter who is now advocating for the
rights of Jason's protesters and says
Trump is the best candidate we have
Donald Trump is also leading Joe Biden
in five of six swing States so as of
right
now it's looked like it's looking like
Donald Trump's going to win for my
polling of my friends which is not that
many people but they're kind of Norm me
it's like Biden's old man that's what
even the people that voted for him are
like this guy's just too old he sucks
too yeah but they don't want old he
didn't want old people they don't want
old people which is also like his same
argument for Trump like he's too old we
need new blood we
have you seen the comparison of I've
ranted about this multiple times on this
show but how old the politicians are now
compared to the normaly like
before do we want Millennial and gen Z
politicians though I
mean it's all Boomers they have no ties
to the current struggles young people
are going through it's insane I totally
get that but I mean just you know and
competence levels right yeah V's 38 he's
a millennial I'll take perhaps part of
the incompetence that has come from
Millennials and Zoomers is that none of
the individuals older than them are
retiring and giving them
power I think it is the the child
ification of humanity that uh uh people
are staying as permanent children so
when I see these videos where it's like
ah adulting it's so hard it's like if
you if you are someone who constantly
looks to the older generation as if
they're in charge instead of looking to
yourself as someone who needs to take
charge you will get this phenomenon you
know who's more terrifying to me than
someone who wants to perpetually be a
child and there is something terrifying
about that is someone who never wants to
retire if you never want to retire and
you want to hold on to power forever
there is something deeply but you can
primary these people the problem is
they're running effectively unopposed
and young people aren't
trying because what what what I see
happening is that they aren't even given
the shot they aren't given the resour
it's not about being given a shot you
have to just do it thing is my point is
every generation sucks right now except
maybe Gen X but they just don't don't
care every generation sucks but uh
Boomers had like what 20% of the wealth
at at the age of Zoomers Millennials and
got like what 4% I totally age they got
186% worse purchasing power yeah no I
totally agree and and the Boomers have a
lot of blame to shoulder for this but I
mean it it doesn't change the fact that
you know the Millennials are not really
capable of governing it as a generation
I mean like you you have your you have
your exceptions like you know I think
you're selling millennials short I don't
blame Boomers for having wealth I blame
Boomers for not educating younger
Generations this nonsense it's all lies
I disagree with everyone here if only
Millennials voted in Canada we would
have a conservative majority government
boomers are more likely to vote for
liberals than Millennials and Canada
there is so much propaganda going
against the younger generation from
Boomers that want to hold on to power
and there are good Boomers I love you
guys don't don't worry but there's a lot
of bad ones that have a lot of power
right so I'm talking about the United
States I'd have to look at the D
obviously I'm Canadian but there's a lot
of propaganda against the mni are
looking at Boomers as if they're always
in charge instead of for whatever reason
like in my life I've had disdain for
everyone older than me all the time just
like it didn't matter who you teacher
you're awful you're stupid I'm I'm I'm
12 and I'm smarter than you even though
I know I'm really not I don't care
you're dumb I'm smart you don't get it
so I get older I'm like I've got to I've
got look they're they're doing it wrong
I can't sense I'm going to go do it but
millennials tend to be like well they're
the one who's the senator they're the
one in charge I can't do it it's not
that no Millennial is doing it it's that
Millennials in general have this
tendency towards assuming the older
generation are the ones who are supposed
to do it not them and I'm I'm talking in
general like you always have your
exceptions right but talking about yeah
I do think there is a kind of sense of
giving up amongst young Generations
they're like the economy is so bad the
world is headed down spiral and they
they just kind of yeah they've given it
okay you guys can do the no no I'm
saying like when you're when you're a
child you ask your parents for
permission Millennials still have that
mentality that they need to ask the
Boomers for permission I I'm like as
soon as you turn 18 you're in charge and
you look the Boomer in the eye and say
shut your mouth I'm the boss now start
Mo but they have all of the money they
have all of the finan most of them boom
so listen with all due respect to
Boomers one of the biggest tropes was
that Boomers didn't understand computers
and they would hire these young people
to come in and pay them abur amount of
money is to fix computers the money is
available to those who seek to to
exploit an Open Marketplace but
Millennials are permanent children
instead of instead of seeking take over
start comp propaganda too many
Millennials are like tell me what to do
daddy well you know what Boomers were
Boomers were helicopter parents can't
you I just going to say can't you blame
that on on as well that's that's what
I'm saying Boomers did awesome stuff and
I actually think boomers are great I
think boomers are more based than the
millennial generation but it is the
Boomers who helped create Millennials
and cre the culture and and generated
the Next Generation Gen X is actually
probably the best and they often the the
reason why Gen X gets overlooked in all
the arguments is because they're doing
fine X had a great everyone's like
everyone forgets about Gen X we're here
too talk
about it's because Gen X is doing all
right X was around before the internet
and like teenagers when it got created
so they saw what it was like before this
Mass manipulation took over and they
know that it can be like that the
Boomers never really understood the
internet and people that were born with
the internet as a normality don't
understand that you can live without
this manipulation and you can use it to
your advantage so well well hold on look
Millennials mostly did not get born into
the internet so I had the internet since
I was as long as I can remember like my
family had the internet in the 80s so we
had Compu serve we had dos shell all
that stuff Windows 3.1 and even before
that whatever and so I grew up quite
literally the internet was always there
most of my friends did not get the
internet until they were teen
gen Z however I think is actually much
more based than Millennials though gen Z
has its issues for sure we can highlight
all the weird woke gen Z gen Z actually
according to Pew I think this was 2018
slightly more conservative in a few
areas so they're comparable to
Millennials but a little bit more based
and I think it may be because many of
these people growing up with the
internet always more so have a view
maybe that you and I do that it's a
propaganda garbage fake reality screw
them I think one of the things is really
important was kind of what you guys were
saying is that that the generalizations
aren't Fair because there are some
brilliant magnificent leaders within
every generation and for a kid right now
or human that was born in like 1990 to
hear us say people in your generation
are lazy they're going to be like I'm
lazy cuz they listen to us and they
believe what we say and there're some
great leaders yeah but hold on be smart
we're not saying literally everyone
we're saying there is a tendency among
certain generations to have a higher
proportion of certain types and we got
to figure out why you're listening to
this you can be better be better we need
you to be better be better but we also
need to be aware of what the time is
like Tim is you're an anomaly you're
very successful very talented on your
own but most people need support systems
that are really strong like I'm talking
like whole families like Italian
Sopranos style like we've got our own
law going on here um and that has
existed for most of human history that
people have had these clubs they've
literally lived on the same properties
with all of their extended families and
it was really the boomer generation that
kind of started this idea of the nuclear
family get out of this house I'm kicking
you out you're making it on your own and
of course people are floundering this is
actually a phenomenon in human history
that people are being kicked out of
their houses at 18 and not kind of
handed a job from the dad from the
grandfather that they've been doing for
ages and ages given that direction and
the fact that they're a bit confused in
asking for direction should not be a
surprise all this is a good point it
used to be and it still it still is in a
lot of ways I went to a maple farm we
went to Pittsburgh two weeks ago on the
way back we stopped at this eight eighth
generation Maple Farm we go side there's
like when you go to the front door the
door is just open there's a sign saying
if you want to buy something give us a
call and I'm like man like in the
country right the store is open with no
one inside it just call us if you want
to buy something they're very trusting
old guy comes in plays a video about how
they make maple syrup showing like old
photos from like the 178 or I'm sorry
not 17 1800s when they were like making
maple syrup and he talks about how they
had this Farm going way back he got it
from his dad who got it from his dad who
got it from his dad he brought his
daughters in his daughters are taken
over now and that's how it used to be
and then industrialization happens you
don't own anything anymore and so when
your kid gets older you say go find a
job somewhere else instead of the dad
being like son when you're old enough
you're this this this blacksmith's Forge
will be yours there is an incredible
rant on this in the second episode of
Fear and Loathing in the New Jerusalem
by martyr maid I don't know if any of
you guys have listened to the podcast
but it's very good and he talks about
how if you ask a man at a random Farm in
the middle of nowhere in the Middle East
who he is he's going to be able to tell
he knows exactly who he is he knows who
his family has been for thousands of
years he knows what his identity is what
his job is you are going to have a tough
time manipulating that man into absurd
ideologies whereas if you ask someone a
modern suburbanite in the city who they
are what did he say he said they don't
need existentialist philosophers there
they they don't need these people asking
who are we because they know we need
those people here because we are such a
diaspora we are so spread out we are
kicked out of our houses we don't know
who our families are we don't know our
history we don't have these lineages of
jobs and were very easily controllable
because of that and very easily confused
because of that you get offered a sense
of identity in the realm of a new
radical ideology every single day on
Twitter Instagram YouTube You're Going
to be desperate for that because there
is nothing you are latched on to in this
world when you are kicked away from your
family and the closest people you have
are nuclear and there's nothing outside
of that
even yeah it's a big problem it's a huge
issue I noticed go for it I just want to
say that that one of the things that
that you're seeing now noway or I think
you're seeing nowadays is the the fact
that human societies don't get to have
the option of not having religion so if
your Society has culture and religion
that's built into it then it's going to
have you know it's going to have certain
things that it does and and everyone
kind of knows their knows how to be in
the world right if you don't have that
if you don't have religion if if that's
taken away or you're you just abandon it
then you end up having Society rep place
a religion that has foundations that
works often times with statism and
that's what you saw that's what nii was
talking about when he said you know God
is dead that's what you saw in the the
Nazi in Nazi Germany that's what you saw
in in communist Russia and China and
it's
because
religion has evolved with human beings
and I don't think that human beings on a
societal level get the option of not
having it if you don't have a
traditional religion your Society will
replace it with something and you see
the bad things that happen when you go
when you try to replace what has worked
for your for societies throughout
history when you see it replaced with
new things and and attempts at new
things nii said when nii said God is
dead he wasn't saying that this is a
good thing he didn't know what was going
to happen he didn't know how people were
going to going to replace it and he
predicted the horrors of communism and
Nazism was and we have killed him and
now we're going to go downhill yeah one
of the things that liberals liberals and
I talk about progressives when I say
liberals I talk about progressives one
of the things that they they tend to do
frequently is talk about oh it's good
that nii you know it's good that God is
dead and and they and it's we need to
evolve Beyond religion
but the evolution is the wrong word
first of all because you don't evolve
unless there's outside forces working on
you you don't it's like human beings
don't just change because it's it's
self-directed EV um self-directed
Evolution now so yeah humanism and all
this stuff it's shown that it doesn't
work though it doesn't work for human
societ it end it ends up it ends in
piles and piles and piles of bodies all
the time I was thinking when someone is
going to develop their sense of self uh
I can only I can tell you what to
believe but you're going to need to tell
me what you believe and that's what I've
noticed about like indoctrination is
like you can tell people you can people
can go online and be told like this is
what I'm supposed to be this is what but
until they have an opportunity to
express themselves it's going to be
challenging to develop themselves and
this is why I like things like X spaces
or opportunities where you throw up a
video chat or an audio chat and people
come in and get the mic and then they
express what they believe and it's like
you're allowing people to develop
themselves and we need more self I mean
that's what a good parent will allow the
kid to tell you what they are I think if
you're constantly telling your kid what
they're going to be what they are it's
like the brain can handle it but they
need you need the entire core system to
experience you know the vibration of of
explaining what I am so more people yeah
it's the most basic act most basic Act
of Creation is to speak right yeah it's
like it's like the it's like the story
in Genesis right God spoke the world
into existence and you know we're made
in the image of God so we have that same
that same kind of power you know what I
mean I I believe that's what that's what
sets us apart and uh so you know um when
it comes to things like censorship it is
is an attack on that Divine image that
you have because you're not expressing
yourself that's it man the word it's
simatic there's like the literally the
vibration I'm into meta materials for
this like etching shape into your your
core your DNA and things with your voice
with the vi it's so important so I
encourage everybody out there to create
spaces to let other people come Express
themselves in your presence thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday Friday at 8:00 p.m. and
become a member over at timcast.net